[Musique]
mais
multiples jury volume être meilleur
mis à danser mais pas que tu te
sentirais
je les garde
marty
ce n'est pas du taf un avis on a pris
des couleurs je compte on a pu noter sur
europe 1
on n'a pas fait les comptes
je sais qu'il va falloir changer at il
promis
il ajouté
[Musique]
et pour cent
aso
à
[Musique]
je sais
fixons faut retrouver la classe et
sincère
[Musique]
on
ah non c'était sa peine à l'heure tu
avais besoin d eux mêmes des avis aussi
l'addiction on a fait des pas retenus et
passif est son courrier et d'éviter le
pire paris dans une spirale infernale du
genre à l'autre
des moments de faiblesse affronter des
mains des partis à la dérive mais il
fallait que tu vives
l'alcool
pas la transition comme la mauvaise
fréquentation du fonds est évadé
tu n'étais pas
[Musique]
1 %
aujourd'hui je sais
sam 6 ans
faut retrouver les classes et son tour
[Musique]
c'est
aussant
les
[Musique]
quand je sers
les mavericks sont retrouvés avec la
descente hauts de seine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]